hi mystery Recaps here today I'm going
to explain an episode from the British
Science Fiction Anthology series Black
Mirror called 15 million merits spoilers
ahead watch out and take care
in the distant future the society that
we know has changed now rich people live
in enormous Villas and have all the
luxuries of Life while the poor are
confined to extremely high-tech but
small facilities the entire day they
have to write exercise cycles and earn a
digital currency called Merit using
these merits they can buy all the
necessities of life like food
entertainment and so on people live in
small rooms that contain screens one can
watch movies or even play games but of
course everything comes at a price the
screens also play adult advertisements
which can only be skipped at the expense
of samarits all the people can build up
their own avatars generally someone with
a good Avatar is considered rich while
the others are poor despite all these
features life is boring inside the
facility as they are confined 24 7 by
highly computerized walls however with
the help of a golden ticket they can
participate in a talent show called Hot
Shot if a person gets selected they can
live a luxurious life they also don't
have to cycle anymore sadly the price of
a golden and ticket is in the millions
the protagonist of the show is a cyclist
named Bing Madsen who has over 15
million merits in his account he doesn't
like buying materialistic things and
tries to live a simple life however he
does skip the adult ads when they pop up
randomly on his screen Bing also loves
playing video games at night especially
the ones where he can shoot things while
he is cycling he mostly prefers
listening to music or watching
Landscapes but the guys next to him
often watch comedy shows live music and
even adult content the true magic of
this world is that these guys know how
to cycle with a half chub there is also
a girl named Sophia who likes to
practice violin while cycling she
appears to have a crush on Bing but
can't put herself together to propose to
him but one day she gets the perfect
opportunity Bing is trying to get an
Apple from the vending machine but it
gets stuck so Sophia Springs into action
and shows him how they can retrieve
stuck objects from the machine she then
tries to initiate a conversation but
Bing simply says thank you and walks
away at while being is engrossed playing
video games suddenly an advertisement of
the Hotshot talent show pops up annoyed
he tries closing his eyes but the alarms
inside his room start blaring this
reveals that one cannot ignore the
advertisements they have to use samarits
to make it go away in the morning as
Bing is on the way to his workplace he
notices a newcomer named ABI Khan Bing
who is usually an introvert becomes
instantly Smitten by her beauty hence
From This Moment onwards he tries to
find a way to chat with her his lucky
day finally arrives in the unlikeliest
of places the bathroom after Bing
finishes his business and gets ready to
depart he suddenly hears Abby singing
beautifully Bing tries to compliment her
but due to his awkward social skills he
can't to make matters worse an adult
advertisement suddenly pops up and ruins
his moment later at work Abby sits on
the opposite row and makes an origami
out of a food wrapper she then places it
on her cycle but moments later a cleaner
takes it away revealing that loitering
is not allowed in the facility all this
while Bing keeps staring at her even at
night he can't stop thinking about Abby
he also sings the song she was humming
in the bathroom just then he sees an ad
for the talent show Hot Shot again and
gets an idea the next morning at work
Bing approaches Abby who is also having
problems with the vending machine he
cheekily teaches her how to retrieve
stuck food items from the machine and
Strikes up a conversation although
nervous Bing says the exact line Sophia
had used on him a few days ago this
impresses Abby and she too starts
opening up she reveals that she just
turned 21 which is the minimum age to
work Abby wanted to go to the facility
where her sister is but it was already
full then at the right opportunity Bing
brings up the time he caught her singing
in the bathroom he compliments her
beautiful voice but Abby plays it down
saying it isn't extraordinary however
Bing thinks that she has a special
talent so he advises her to give an
audition on hot shot he even offers to
pay the entry fee which is 12 million
merits on her behalf Bing reveals that
he inherited the merits after his
brother Pat passed away last year he
doesn't like buying fancy clothes eating
expensive food or updating his Avatar in
short he doesn't like materialistic
things so he wants something real to
happen like Abby getting popular for her
Talent as expected she refuses to take
up the offer but when Bing promises to
be by her side all the time she agrees
at night after getting back to his room
Bing learns that the rate for the golden
ticket has increased it now costs a
whopping 15 million merits which is
almost everything that Bing has
nonetheless he buys the ticket as it has
become his mission to impress Abby
shortly after he sends it to her making
her excited in return Abby sends him a
virtual kiss thus kick-starting a
special relationship between the two
early the next morning they skip work
and head to the location where the
Hotshot auditions are taking place
inside the elevator Abby gives Bing a
penguin origami as a thank you gift she
explains that it is flat so he can hide
it wherever he wants after a while Bing
sees how nervous Abby is so he holds her
hand to calm her down out once they
reach the audition set Abby is allowed
to enter Because she has the ticket but
Bing has to be verified first he is
given a painful temporary tattoo on his
hand which registers him as Abby's
friend soon the two reach a room which
is full of other auditioners they are
practicing their respective talents some
are singing some are dancing while some
are just blabbering around it is
revealed that many of these auditioners
have waited for almost a week now but to
everyone's surprise Abby is almost
immediately called up this is because of
her beautiful looks some auditioners
take this angrily and to demand justice
but the bouncer simply tells them that
he's just following orders meanwhile
Abby is asked to face the camera and
record a short promotional line I want
to be famous then she has hurried
backstage where a staff member hands her
a drink called compliance Abby says that
she doesn't want it but she is told that
it is mandatory for all the auditioners
to calm their nerves and keep them from
puking hence reluctantly Abby takes a
few sips and as soon as she does so she
starts getting dizzy despite this Abby
goes on stage to perform her act while
Bing watches her excitedly from
backstage there are three judges the
scary yet understanding one hope the
fashion Diva charity and the guy who is
in charge of all the adult content in
the country wraith initially because of
the extreme nervousness Abby is unable
to introduce herself properly so hope
encourages her to just perform however
wraith simply wants her to reveal her
skin he is flabbergasted by her beauty
and doesn't care if she can sing or not
despite this Abby ignores him and starts
singing as the entire country watches an
excitement she sings a perfect rendition
of anyone who knows what love is will
understand this astounds the judges as
well as the digital avatars that are
witnessing the live performance
unfortunately hope Cuts Abby short and
explains that while this is the best
singing performance they have had all
year it is only good not great the quota
for singers is already full and only an
extraordinary performance can make the
cut now however Abby does have something
extraordinary which the entire our
country is desperate to see her body
hope adds that Abby would become a
superstar if she agrees to be part of
wraith's adult company this would be the
only way she can have a lavish life a
life where she doesn't have to cycle
anymore as soon as he says this the
other two judges also start pressuring
Abby to say yes even the crowd chips in
and starts chanting do it bing who is
watching all of this from backstage
becomes angry and tries rescuing her but
the security swiftly apprehends him and
takes him away at last Abby who is still
under the influence of compliance
becomes overwhelmed by the chance and
says yes she does so with tears in her
eyes meaning that she does not consent
to it wholeheartedly a few days later we
see Bing in his room fidgeting with the
penguin origami that Abby had given him
he is still distraught over how things
turned out and blames himself for the
entire incident in addition to being sad
Bing is also broke he barely has the
merits to afford healthy foods so he is
forced to eat whatever he gets his hands
on one night while Bing is in his room
playing video games suddenly an adult
advertisement pops up to his horror it
is Abby's first movie since he has no
merits left to skip it bing immediately
covers his eyes and tries to avoid
watching it but the blaring alarms are
so high pitched that he can't stand it
for more than a few seconds reluctantly
he opens his eyes and tries going out
but the door just won't open it turns
out that if an advertisement plays there
is no way to evade it except for
coughing up a few thousand merits Bing
has no choice but to watch and all he
notices is a heartbroken Abby having had
enough he goes crazy and starts slamming
the screens until one of them breaks as
Bing screams in desperation he notices a
glass Shard on the floor and an idea
strikes his mind from the next day he
puts all his energy into collecting
merits Bing is the first one to show up
at work so he uses a tiny amount of
toothpaste to brush his teeth and he
doesn't buy food anymore Bing eats
leftovers of his colleagues and also the
fruits stuck in the vending machine to
satiate his hunger at night he doesn't
play games anymore instead he practices
dancing something which she hasn't done
all his life and in a matter of months
he manages to amass 15 million merits
Bing finally has enough to buy his own
golden ticket which is the first step of
his plan the following day he hides The
Shard of glass and the empty compliance
packet inside his clothes and heads to
audition for Hotshot Bing is the first
person to arrive but soon hundreds of
people crowd the room fortunately he
doesn't have to wait for long as the
bouncer is ordered to find someone
ethnic next Bing is asked to cut a
promotional line but he simply says I'm
an Entertainer once he reaches backstage
a staff member hands to make Appliance
drink but he rejects it saying he has
already had it bing shows the empty
packet he sneaked in as proof following
this he is finally allowed on stage
seeing his appearance the judges don't
say much and they ask him to get on with
it bing complies and he starts his
performance it is a highly energetic
dance which is a result of months of
practice and also the anger that has
been building inside of him the judges
appear to be fascinated by his moves but
just then being stops his performance
and takes out the glass Shard he then
points it at himself and threatens to
commit the unthinkable if anyone gets
close to him wraith who seems to be
unconcerned challenges him to do it but
hope and charity say otherwise they
order the guards to stand down and
politely ask Bing what he wants the
latter says just listen and he starts
ranting about the system that is
controlling them at first he chastises
the judges for treating everyone like
fodder they take anyone who is beautiful
and dump others even if they have talent
Bing also bad maths the audience and
calls them sheep he mentions that no one
in the country is brave enough to stand
up against the system all their lives
they have been controlled and tormented
but still they have no problem with it
by the time Bing is done with his speech
the entire audience goes numb they can't
believe what they just heard however
they again start screaming when hope
mentions that this was the most
heartfelt speech he has ever heard he
then manipulates Bing by saying that his
message is a good one but in order to
transmit it to a wider audience he has
to keep on speaking hence hope offers
Bing to talk on his channels twice a
week in exchange for an insane amount of
money hearing this Charlie says she
definitely watches show while wraith
labels the glass Shard gimmick a neat
one and just like the last time the
audience also starts chanting do it the
pressure is too much for Bing so at the
end he sells out he agrees to do the
very thing he wanted to change a few
days later Bing starts his new show
where he speaks all about the system
with rage in his eyes he has continued
with the glass Shard gimmick and the
show quickly becomes a hit the story
ends as we get a glimpse of Bing's new
life he no longer has to cycle as he now
has all the wealth he could wish for
Bing can drink orange juice every day he
has a proper figurine of a penguin and
most importantly he can see the outside
world which is full of lush vegetation
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching